I wanted to ask you a
couple things about that.
So you know,
the big five research into political
differences basically shows that the
liberals are high in trade,
openness and low and treat
conscientiousness and
the conservatives or the
reverse,
but we've fragmented conscientiousness
into orderliness and industriousness with
the big five aspect scale and orderliness
is strongly associated with disgust,
so so,
right,
exactly.
It does sound a lot like Freud but it,
but it also is in accordance with your
observations that conservatives have neat
spaces,
for example.
So,
so now and they're meeting start on time.
Yes.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
So,
so then the next is for political
belief seems to be openness,
so that that exploratory tendency that
you talked about exploration of ideas and
creativity and low orderliness.
And so then I thought,
well why in the world would,
why would the political nexus
go across those dimensions,
which are some relatively uncorrelated?
Then I thought,
and this is in keeping with
your work on discussed,
is that it's an issue of borders,
which of course seems more or less self
evident in the wake of Trump's election
when he talked about borders.
But you might say,
and I think this is reasonable,
that the conservative is someone who
wants the borders between categories to
remain intact no matter
what level of analysis.
So it's borders from the
highest resolution level of
cognition all the way up to
the actual physical borders of,
of,
of rooms,
towns,
states,
countries,
all of that.
So the borders should be thicker
and the reason they want that.
Now there is a paper
published in plause one,
I don't know if you saw it,
it was a couple of years ago.
It was a mind boggling paper.
It should have been like front page
news as far as I was concerned.
And what the researchers did was between
countries and then within provinces or
states within countries,
they correlated the level of um,
of frequency of infectious disease with
authoritarian political beliefs and
found a wallop correlation.
It was like 0.6.
It was one of the highest by far,
for those of you who don't know,
social scientists never discover anything
that's associated with anything else
at a correlation of 0.6
other than heritability.
Right.
Other than heritability.
Yes.
And so what they found was that the higher
the prevalence of infectious disease,
the higher the probability of,
of totalitarian authoritarian
political attitudes.
And then they controlled for governance
because one of the questions was,
was this top down authoritarianism
or bottom up authoritarianism?
And the answer was that
it was bought them up.
Okay.
And so I thought about that in two from
two perspectives simultaneously at the
time.
Okay.
So we identified disgust,
sensitivity with orderliness.
So let's say a fundamental sub trait.
Then I was reading this book that
was called Hitler's table talk.
And it was,
uh,
it was the recordings of virtually
everything he said at dinner from 1939 to
1942.
Yeah.
So it's a spontaneous utterance say,
and,
um,
it's full of discussions about Jews and
Gypsies and all the people he tormented.
But what's really interesting is
all the language is discussed.
It's not fear.
So,
so Hitler's basic metaphor was that the
Aryan race and country was a pure body,
and then it was assaulted by parasites.
Right.
And then I remembered what happened to
the native Americans when the Europeans
showed up and she'll cans.
What happened was that 95% of
them were dead within 50 years.
Right.
Because of smallpox and measles.
And so that,
that border issue that separates
conservatives from liberals,
let's say as the conservative,
say the novel is potentially contaminated.
It's not so much that it's dangerous.
That's different.
That's fear.
It's contaminated.
And the Liberals say,
hold on a minute.
If you make the borders too thick,
then information can't pass through.
Exactly.
That's the Omnivore's dilemma right there.
Right,
right.
And then since we have a
biological architecture on,
which are cognitive platforms are erected,
we have the same attitude
towards abstract information,
which would be ideas that we
do to things like food or,
or illness.
Right?
Right.
And so we can think of an invading idea
or a polluting idea or contaminated.
That's right.
Now I'm a big fan of
George Lakoff metaphors.
We live by a,
that we,
yeah,
we use our bodily,
our bodily ski Mada to
think about abstract things
like politics and like what
our policies should be about
borders and immigration.
Uh,
there's a Canadian psychologist,
Mark Shaller,
he and his colleagues have developed
what they call an account of these,
the behavioral immune system,
right.
That we don't just try to,
you know,
microbes killed probably many more of
our ancestors then did lions and tigers
and bears.
And so whoever can keep themselves and
their children from being exposed to
fatal illnesses wins
the evolutionary game.
And so a lot of that is
judging carefully about people.
Is he dangerous?
Is She dangerous?
And that's both for sexuality,
for contact,
for all kinds of association.
Um,
so yeah,
and a lot of ways our emotions and
our bodily interactions structure,
how we think and feel about,
about social,
well,
even with the black death in Europe,
I mean,
so the black death occurred in Europe
when the Europeans started to move around
the world and they brought
back rats that were infected.
Exactly.
So,
so what you saw there was both of
those forces at work at the same time.
So the European expansion produced a
tremendous interchange of ideas from all
around the world.
That's globalization,
but it wiped out somewhere between 30
and 60% of the population at the same
time.
Yeah.